steel ball run yeah perhaps overrated
star notion probably underrated
subscribing to the new alt review in
order to receive regular Jojo content
uploaded straight into your YouTube feed
hmm I would say perfectly rated hello
and welcome to the new order video
source for everything anime and manga
and it's Jojo this time around as it
often is at this time of week and today
we will be diving into the topic of
steel ball run a near universally
praised segment of this epic tale and I
say near universally praised because
steel ball run certainly has no shortage
of critics but whenever I encounter a
piece of media with this kind of
disparity I do feel the ever annoying
need to ask myself well could it be
overrated and to begin any discussion
along these lines though it is always
important to unpack that annoying word
for a bit you know overrated and
underrated are quite possibly two of the
top 10 most common words that I see in
any anime or manga fandom on the
Internet
they can both be applied to anything and
everything whether that be say the power
of a particular character or an arc in
the story or even an entire series as a
whole as we will be examining here with
steel ball run and my personal belief on
the matter is that it is nearly
impossible for any series to meet that
delicate balance of not being overhyped
or undersold and so to illustrate let's
take an example of what I would believe
to be a solidly
good series being my hero academia it is
good it is a competent piece of Shonen
storytelling that is largely enjoyable
with charming characters and that has
led to great experiences with the series
and a massive fan base developing who
may tell many non my hero academia fans
that this series is amazing and so when
a person like that hears such a
statement and decides to check it out
despite all of its merits my hero
academia might not live up to that brand
of amazing thus making it overrated but
at the same time this commences a deadly
spiral of online discourse because that
person who did not get the experience
they were promised is now probably
telling others that this series is
horrible and overrated rah-rah-rah which
rather twisted Lee kind of leads to my
hero academia being underrated by a that
particular person so two very stark
schools of thought emerged whereby the
series is either horrific Lee overhyped
or criminally underrated it's very
difficult to find that sweet sweet
balance and steel ball run may find
itself in a similar position because
when I pose this question to my
community a lot of answers I got were
the peak of praise there were
a lot of people who labeled steel boron
is our keys magnum opus which I actually
think I might have done as well in a
video no less but a surprising amount
went even further and called it the best
piece of literature in the history of
human media and Wow oh wow
that is an incredibly grand statement to
make and to anybody who hears that
having not read still wallrun they are
almost certainly going to go into the
series and come out of it with an
impression of their that was a bit
overrated and just like with the my hero
academia example some of these people
are also quite liable to snap to the
other extreme and call it a pretty meh
series because it did not meet the
proposed standard of being the best
story ever told
however this is much less common in the
Georgia fanbase mind you in regards to
this particular part anyway which i
think does speak to the fantastic
quality of steel ball run I mean I've
only been a part of this jo-jo realm for
a brief period of time comparatively but
even when I posed this question directly
I have a very very difficult time
finding a huge amount of criticism of
steel boron that isn't as a direct
result of heavily built-up expectations
that isn't to say that there isn't any
and we will certainly get into it but I
feel like that really does speak volumes
about the genuine quality of part seven
because I would personally not say that
it has any potential fatal flaws whereas
I think there is a solid argument to be
made that every other Georgia part does
and maybe that's not such a great idea
to get into here though but speaking of
other parts there is another fun human
phenomena that occurs with this whole
overrated underrated business because
what happens when we put steel ball run
on a golden pedestal is that it kind of
depresses the impression of every other
part in comparison so let's take another
what I would say is a widely loved part
being diamond is unbreakable now there
is a lot more of a solid argument when
we get to the top tier asking people
about their particular favorite part but
if one was to say that say steel ball
run was the greatest thing in literally
all of human history and it would you
know less than that impression of part
four which may very well lead to time it
is unbreakable being underrated and then
the part for super fans could adopt a
stance of Steel boron definitely being
overrated it's a really tricky thing and
my belief is that once discussion
expands beyond one individual which I
guess would be more of a monologue than
a discussion in any case once it expands
beyond the thoughts of a single person
there is no such thing as a series or a
character or anything that is not either
overrated or underrated it will always
fall into one
those category is often both actually
because once something is overrated then
it generates haters leading to it being
underrated which generates lovers and so
on and so forth
so is steel ball run technically
overrated almost certainly it is
probably also underrated on the odd
occasion as well but to even achieve
that first step the series does need
some substance to it at the very least
something that readers can latch onto
and claim is fantastic and in the case
of part 7 there are no shortage of often
cited reasons for this being our keys
magnum opus the first of which is the
general claim that steel ball run is
quote unquote peak Araki you know that
this is the point in his career where
the stars aligned and it resulted in
steel ball run this was the time when
Archie Hansel defied his art style which
over three decades had seen quite a
rapid transformation and refinement and
by this point in Jojo his experience as
a visual artist was unparalleled and
that mastery is on full display in part
seven in addition to that Stillwell Run
is generally cited as the height of
Archie storytelling which is another
thing I'm almost certain than I said in
my review of the series as well but
story in Pride Jojo Potts specifically
three to six I guess was something of a
technical necessity a thing that existed
in order to explore some fun stand
battles whereas the narrative upon seven
very much stands out in comparison
because Archie has undeniably become a
more effective storyteller with each pot
from Stardust Crusaders onwards in each
subsequent part arc you learn to
integrate more of a solid narrative into
his work and it only makes sense that
part seven would see something of an
epitome of this as well as arguably its
successor Jojo Leone and once again
along the same lines with every
subsequent part Archie has become much
more creative actually which is a
strange thing to ponder because you
would think that by this stage he would
be burnt out of ideas but that just
isn't the case and the most evident
thing for this is stands for any anime
only fans of chocha watching this video
in terms of stands I must say you
haven't seen anything yet in my personal
opinion many of the most intriguing
stands in the series come directly from
part six to eight because our key is
really forced to delve into the more
complex and blatantly bizarre ideas
because all of the basic stuff has
already been done and yes I am hyping up
your expectations here which may lead to
you being disappointed by the stands but
I really don't think so in addition to
this deal boron features what are
arguably two of the greatest
protagonists that Archie has ever put to
page and most certainly the most
memorable duo of the entire giorgo saga
they
both have quite an impressive geology
about them because they tend to exist in
a great area of life like Johnny is
outwardly a fairly reasonable person but
harbors a pretty terrifying darkness
within him and gyro was more of an
antagonistic element but with a heart of
gold as well as dthe lots of gold teeth
and of course they balance each other
out quite nicely and to complement this
steel ball run also features two of the
most revered antagonists in the series
being funny Valentine and deercup Rondo
Valentine in particular has a huge
following and seems to eye the charm or
intrigue people at great length whilst
iego the alternate universe dear gets to
take advantage of everything that that
character presented in the original
universe just with a much more subtle
and identifiable take I would say that
he is more inviting a deer which at
times generally makes you root for Diego
and that is a truly strange feeling but
I love it and that actually brings up
another huge element of Steel bull run
because it is not just deer this series
is uniquely placed to take advantage of
everything that parts one through six
had built there are references
absolutely everywhere and it can be
incredibly fun to experience or identify
those alternate incarnations the figures
that we know and love or even no one
hate so to recognize certain names and
go oh well hi you're probably this
incarnation of this guy or the ancestor
of this universe is this guy and so on
and so forth so in a way still boron has
a lot less pressure to act as its own
standalone story which is another one of
those strange things to think about
because I feel like the general
consensus would be that this would
probably make the best standalone
feature of any part of Georgia but I
don't know at the same time it's pretty
intrinsically linked to Jo Jo and in
many ways both this and Part A to
present themselves as a greatest hits of
the Georgia realm and personally I do
agree with all of the above I would also
add the decision to have the pot take
place entirely within the setting of a
cross-country race was a stroke of
brilliance because it very effectively
added a layer of urgency in the
background and I would also personally
posit that pretty much every side
character was a compelling existence
figures like Lucy Mountain Tim hot pants
book Aloka Ringo backup oboe Sandman
Scarlett and so so many more are all
paramount figures that come to my mind
whenever I think about Steel will run
the cast is on an entirely different
level to the characters of any previous
parts many of whom were just having
their own little arc and then promptly
be discarded but that is just my
experience I'm sure there are many out
there who would argue strongly for
signed characters of various other parts
because they just hit them that much
more potently I think gold
would be a good candidate for that but
is steel ball run all it's cracked up to
be
and look I'm not trying to claim that my
community posed to it close to 300
responses is anything empirical or even
statistically relevant it's not but over
the very few people who agreed with the
sentiment the part 7 was overrated it
was always for one of two reasons
firstly they would say yes but so is all
of Georgia and I'm sure that some of
these people were not even fans of the
series and some who do enjoy Jojo but
have more lackluster opinion of the body
of work as a whole neither of which
actually contribute anything towards
this particular discussion about steel
ball run because it's more comment on
the series as a whole but the second and
more substantive reasoning was that
steel ball run is overrated because the
beginning of first third of it is
quote-unquote solo and look there's
something that yes I can agree with I
mean I think steel ball run has a
fantastic opening handful of chapters
but after that things do take a bit kick
into gear whereas most other parts have
left the opposite impression on me they
start out balls to the wall and then
they stagnate a bit through the middle
before picking up rapidly at the end so
steel ball run is a strange property
where it goes through the stagnation
phase very early on whilst the middle
and the conclusion are in my opinion
nothing short of brilliant but that is
problematic because when someone has
been told that something is the greatest
story ever written and they encounter
say 30 chapters of slowish set up and
that sort of thing can really play on
them and also this is just my personal
speculation but I have a feeling that a
lot of people who did not enjoy steel
boron also might be reluctant to speak
up about that experience primarily
because whenever somebody does their
opinion seems to be immediately
assaulted by another and look no it's
not a popular thing to criticize do bull
run and the culture around that is so
obvious that it might just be easier to
stay quiet but one final reason I will
give for steel ball run potentially
being overrated is that it is juxtaposed
directly against stone ocean which is
like a hate sink for Georgia pots it's a
really good example of the opposite
effect actually a part that gets so so
much negativity that it is almost
certainly underrated but next to that
just about anything is going to look
fantastic as a result which generally
seems to benefit not only steel ball run
but also golden wind but in the end I
think this is a strictly technical case
of a four high steel ball run has
problems when people make the grander
statement possible about it but at the
very least in my explorations I have not
encountered much too
bonk it as a property from 99% of
accounts I've seen it is a solid story
and a phenomenal Church apart even from
those who are underwhelmed by it but
that seems to be entirely as a result of
the fans rather than steel boron itself
and if you do have some more substantive
criticism of part 7 then please do leave
it in the comments below because I would
love to hear more legitimate issues that
people do take with it and for anyone
who does see a comment like this please
don't immediately like [ __ ] all over it
because I do think that stuff like this
is a very valuable discussion but what
do you guys think please do let me know
down in the comments below or even join
my discord server and if you're keen for
some old Giorgio's content and please do
go check out some my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel for
regular Georgia Wanda delivered straight
until YouTube feed but for now this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time